انها عاصفه القرن هكذا وصف عدد من
المسؤولين الامريكيين العاصفه الثلجيه
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده
من البحيره الكبرى شمال قرب كندا الى
اليوغرادي على الحدود مع المكسيك جنوبا
شله العاصفه الحركه تقريبا لم تتمكن فرق
الاسعاف من تلبيه النداءات استغاثه كثيره
لان الثلوج احتلت اغلب الطرق العشرات
توفوا بسبب هذه العاصفه اما في بيوتهم او
في سياراتهم التي غمرتها الثلوج او اثناء
محاولاتهم ازاحه الثلوج من امام بيوتهم
سجلت وفيات في اثني عشر ولايه منها
نيويورك وكلورادو ومشيجن ومن سوريا ونبراس
واكله هوما وبينما انخفضت الدراجات
الحراره الى ارقام قياسيه انقطع التيار
الكهربائي عن مئات الالاف من البيوت
الامريكيه في يوم السبت الماضي في اوجي
العاصفه بلغ عدد البيوت التي انقطع عنها
التيار نحو مليون و700,000 بين
بيتناكم لا تسافروا فما يحدث ويهدد حياتكم
هذا نداء نداءات كثيره وجهها مسؤولون
امريكيون
لثاني الناس عن السفر لكن هذه العاصفه
الثلجيه تصادف اعياد الميلاد وهناك من
يغامر بالسفر للاحتفال مع اقاربها كثير
منهم علقوا في مطارات مثل بافال ودينبر
وديترويت الغيت اكثر من 15,000 رحله جويه
بسبب هذه العاصفه الثلجيه كان هذا حاله
كثير من الركاب الذين كانوا يؤمنون النفس
بقضاء اعياد الميلاد مع ذويهم
مدينه بفلو ثاني اكبر مدن ولايه نيويورك
من اكثر مناطق الولايات المتحده تضررا
بالعاصفه فالمدينه التي يقطنها نحو
275,000 سنه وجدت نفسها غارقه في الثلوج
وسجلت اكبر عدد من الضحايا اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بارد حاله الطوارئ في نيويورك
بمساعدتها على مواجهتها هذه العاصفه
عزيزه ما يحدث هنا مناعه من يعتقدون ان
الاحتباس الحراري بسبب تدمير النظام
البيئي ليصبح تطرفه والعنف السمه الغالبه
على الظواهر الطبيعيه